you know we've talked a lot on the show
about vintage shopping for clothes it's
made a huge comeback but it's not just
for you know clothes people are dealing
with other things too vogue reports the
second head market for furniture is
really on fire online resellers like
cherish say business has grown 60
percent drew people want cheaper
sustainable furnishings and they don't
care if it's brand new it's a great way
to find special items at a discount i do
this all the time in palm springs i'm
always on the lookout for um like a
vintage chair that's a great destination
for vintage shopping totally it's i even
bought a pickup drew you know drive a
pickup mm-hmm and palm street oh yeah
can we put like a just married sign on
it with a bunch of cans hanging off the
back please i'll decorate it okay with
the leftover flowers yeah
but i do i love it i love finding a
one-of-a-kind piece yeah you know um i
found these to end tables at a thrift
store called angel view it's a charity
thrift store and i bought them for like
35 and then i googled them and they were
worth like like almost a thousand
dollars you know you can find amazing
things
out in the world if you just sort of
go through the stores clap of pants
who's into vintage shops
clap of hands who was like i am not
putting my butt on that youth couch
oh i like it ladies
and you're like really in cahoots about
it which is great
[Music]